癒しも緑皆さんこんにちははじめ社長です皆さん rpg のゲームやって来ており
ますでしょうか
まあ有名なものだったまあまあポケモンとかドラッグへとかファイナルファンタジーと
か
僕の好きなマザー2と色々あるんですけども後 v ドラッグへとかですね仲間が
増えるんですよ
阿部をしてる釣り仲間が増えるんですけどもその仲間ってどうやってついてくるかと
いいますと
本当にいい
象なぐらい主人公の背中にぴったりともう
隙間ないぐらいのキュールずーっとついてくるんですよ同コーナーで日やばくないです
か
ゲームの世界だからって何かこの普通にするするんですけどまぁよくよく考えてみると
ですね一緒に冒険する仲間の主人公誰かの背中にぺったりくっついて
し6人中24時間投稿に行く時も
徒歩に解任に行くとにもめるとてもフッ化なるときでも延々に主人公にも
だけ苦痛に移動するわけですよこれガチでヤベェなと思いまして
基本的に主人公の仲間になったやつだってあの無口なんですよねまったく知らない
けれども無言でずっと所神宮2分らしい
くっついずっとついていくんですけどもそんな rpg の世界の仲間の動きをですね
今
実際に前列世界でやってみようかなと思いますが現地生ですねあの仲間になった人に
そんなも出されるとかつで恐怖を覚えて警察署に優れ米だと思うんですけども今回は
ターゲットに主人公になってもらって
あとのターゲットに使える仲間パーティーの一人としてそいつにずっと荒れてじっパイ
に抜くつでずっとくっついて行ってみようかなと思いますねその結果主人公はどうなる
んでしょうか
ベア子どうんだああああ
なあ
wh
ああああああ
じゃ回以上ではい
ああああああああ
ええええええ
word ずっ
えっ
うん
ああああああ
加盟
[音楽]
うわぁやったら惚れしかねーっ
安倍晋かああっ他の方かはいっ
何か出るとが何か良い奴来いん
なぜ増車スカ英断がどうしたんですか
before これいいです柄って
s 5位
すごいかいいん
意外なにやにゃんとレッツすごいする
えって言ってる
[音楽]
ん
何かあるとか
この中に撮っ
なんかがきっとある
産地やん
何なんだ
r
ん
[音楽]
い
かんなぁでも考えどういう意味はどういう女って言ってるんだけど
a 困る困る困る映画にやバエ
俺馬鹿だから何もわかんない何何何複数ボス boss なんだってなんだってやばい
やばいやばい
[音楽]
wh
何へ
何だろう
分かったずっとついていったらさて目は一応これのみなります
違うん
ないしに使うですか
1回コンビニに行ってみるのもアリかもしれないねぇ
皆さんみんな込
[音楽]
えええええんマジでどんどんだろうか
ています
持っている
[音楽]
[拍手]
ふぅん
aname
ani
ん
[音楽]
暑いですね
だったん
[音楽]
同社+かさっきから何か6近いですかどうしてわかんない
よねうんうん
あっはっは
ああああああ
くれちょっとポップスったらクラの予想とデータ移動車パンクどうしちゃっています
おっしゃったんですけど
re ん
[音楽]
ちょっと分けるっっ
てるんじゃない
えっ本当クルー
ザッツ足売っ
ちょっとワークありがとうございましょうちょっと
だーっ
[笑い]
papanda
ん
は行ったらん
[音楽]
質問[ __ ]ランディまずフライパンですか a だって唯一
また喋っとそっちから脱却パンってなえっ
[音楽]
持っ
それでいきますもう
を祝したいんだよ
何がいいとへ邪魔じゃなくだけ
分かった絶対というわーきたん今で打ったいっぱいだよねー
ねこういったところだといまハイパーに入っ丼
全然を知ってい
me
rar
car
re いっ